what's good man congratulations bro i
didn't know you had a little one out
here i can't believe y'all heard making
children you need to be responsible stop
playing video games i'm just kidding
never stop playing video games congrats
though homie congrats though homie
my man out here changing diapers with
the tekken hands oh bro
all right here we go legacy
the legacy skills there you go okay wow
so with the knee with the um
this is a forbidden word in my
vocabulary that's why it's like oh wow
negan huh
yeah yeah i like [ __ ] dude he's
underrated
he's like my favorite guest character by
far
bro i think it's so cool man that
i still think it's crazy that we have
jeffrey being morgan and tekken bro
actually like because i'm telling you
right now if the chance ever comes where
i meet him i'll be like i can't believe
you're in tekken bro do you know how
powerful that is he's like dude i'm the
best
wayne i'm like i know he's i'm the
comedian you know in a movie i'm like
dude i get it
but you're jeffrey d morgan and you're
in tekken bro you're in cursing there's
not a lot of people to get to do that
yeah yeah that's a repeat
okay there's an order for you
oh boy he's giving him the smorgasbord
okay
oh goes right over it yeah yeah can't
break the wall oh no actually you take
the power bomb
goes for a stump oh okay well this is
this is definitely possible wowser
pokes them oh yo
down 4-1 and gets out of the range of
the devil
wait a minute the wowser oh my god he
stole that yep
wowza just his play style with any
character is a treat i just love
watching wilde's play style
damn he hit him with the chest hair
freshly shaved chest
it's that prickly chest that's why he
got him stunned him
it's growing out for a little bit
you don't know exactly
you don't even know what it is it's like
man i don't know if i was annoyed or i
want to giggle that's going to hit the
wall
am i annoyed that i'm giggling i don't
know hey look i don't even know which
one i don't even know what happened am i
turned on or am i i know it i don't know
all right goes for the low
oh my god look at this is annoying right
now
god like how does he do this man it's
crazy how he had like one like that that
you know that corrado steamy hp steamy
and he managed to bring the health all
the way back though right like even
though he was one type away just that
push and pull getting in getting his
head going out and then just chipping
from the distance that he's got with his
tool kit and there you go just gets the
round
yeah nachos does have to fish a little
bit to get like big
damage at the tail end right so
going for the poke sticking to the poke
game is really really smart because you
expect if even if i have that lead right
like i'm i'm expecting you to go for
something big i'm not thinking that
you're gonna keep going for these small
pokes uh just to like keep the match
going on a little bit longer that takes
a lot to do especially in situations
these top eight situations where you got
to keep your wits about you so i like
the play style man the knock is getting
the job done
oh yeah
and it's not a very common character you
see in tournament play like even when i
went to evo
and you know that's when you see a lot
of play right i saw how many matches
there it was a probably a couple two or
three necklaces that were just like very
good like that you'd see them and
they'll just do really well
so as we said like our character paul
oppa hey
hello the zuya's out finally yeah the
guest character from super smash bros
ultimate is here bro i can't believe the
character from they got a stage from
super smash brothers
let's go dlc supremacy dlc supremacy
let's go you guys gonna be cracked i'm
telling you
man i'm gonna tell you right now man
i love that i love the tears bro
oh god the electrics you're gonna hit
them with three in the beginning of the
round you disrespectful
that's called bread and butter in the
casio world okay three electrics is
brilliant three electrics is the bread
and butter
that's your vegemite and toast that's
the vegemite and butter dude
make sure you tell them how much
vegemite
how much vegetables
he just spoons it straight out though he
doesn't give a damn he treats like
nutella
why would you talk about kazuya players
like that bro you just go sit there
eating spoonfuls
oh my god
chad yes
i'ma tell you right now if i come back
and i catch somebody doing that i'm just
gonna slap it out their hand man i'm
like you need jesus man you can't be out
here eating vegemite like this bro this
can't be healthy
this can't be healthy
a lot of sodium
too much salt
oh
yo the butter knife
oh the water
okay that should do it there you go
that was a pretty decent round look
pretty long
and it's all pulled up
wowzers not getting any big combos but
still staying alive just as i say that
the four one plus two yeah but it's not
generally not what is part of his style
he's not really looking for that he's
looking for like it look it seems like
he does combos as like a bonus
look at that right he's got like this
god like it's like if he gets a combo
opportunity oh [ __ ] i'll take it but hey
i don't need it
yo man i love that move
hi hi watch out
is going to the living room gonna put on
his pants go to the living room
scorpion out of this tlc wows are gonna
stay alive in the loser side of things
that is
yeah the character switch was pretty
telling the character switch was
actually pretty telling for scorpion uh
once he see that the king was not
working out and that knocked his game